speaking of the best
who are some of the most credible people
in this ufo
seen either
people who are eyewitnesses or
researchers themselves this question
comes from paul walsh and essentially i
want to know the same but with regard to
physics
well i'm glad you talked with eric davis
because i i mean
i'm not a physicist and i'm not
qualified to comment but i mean i listen
to davis and i think this man's
i don't know about being a genius but
he's super brilliant and he and he knows
he knows things
davis has been briefed into things he
knows a lot so anything you can pry out
of him is worth prying out
uh same with how put off
um hal talks much less in davis
but in terms of research well people in
the field travis walton who came up i
think earlier in the conversation i have
nothing but admiration for travis great
i'm speaking with him next week i've
known him many years i did a
i drove across a state of state of
pennsylvania with him once it was a six
hour plus drive
but i've hung out with travis on many
many many many occasions and um
i have only have the best regard for him
personally and i
there's no doubt in my mind that he's a
completely truthful man none none at all
um in terms of researchers
you always want to hear what linda
moulton howe has to say whether you
agree with her or not linda to me is a
lion
i adore her and i respect her
um i haven't always agreed with
everything that has come out of her
research
but you know what like i don't i don't
have to agree with someone 100 of the
time
to find them worthwhile
i don't do that so if someone's wrong
about something once in a while well you
know then they're wrong
but i have a very high regard for linda
um
i'm a fan of nick redfern
nick's people don't know nick as well as
they should nick's a very prolific
author
i respect his last name
redfern
red fern
um he's a bridge who's moved to the u.s
nick's written a lot of books
i have disagreed with some of his theses
over the years but overall i have mad
respect for his
integrity as a researcher i really like
him
um who else there's a lot of researchers
who will have good things to say i'm
interested in ross cole hart so i'm glad
someone mentioned ross
i don't know if he's a genuine ufo
researcher or just a damn good
journalist who got into the ufo field
however you look at it but he's worth
listening to
um
how do i identify misinformation
in this field
or how does one identify so this can
this dr kickass 77 wants to know this i
want to know it personally
when i wrote uh ufos for the 21st
century mind that was 20 what 13 2014 i
think
i had one section on the development of
ufology and i spent back then a few
pages on things that you could do as an
armchair researcher
i think overall they're still valuable
um
back then reverse image searches were
kind of a new thing and i've talked i
wrote about i was like look
there's ways that you can do your own
research
i talked about that or very similar like
sometimes if someone has a photograph
for example that's an alleged this or
that or whatever like search it find out
what you want to do with any story
is look for the origin
where is the first instance of this
claim originating ever
like you want to do that all the time
and sometimes that's easy and sometimes
it's difficult sometimes you can figure
that out in 10 minutes of searching
sometimes it might take weeks or you
never even get the answer but you try
you've got to always find out where did
this thing
you have to do that
so any claim
and
and then you know just basic rules like
you wanna
you follow certain protocols
so when someone makes a claim a
statement
depends on the information you ask
yourself can this
is has this information been
thoroughly debunked anywhere
you start with that
and then when if it has been allegedly
debunked you got to check the debunker
like are they
really legit or are they just playing
their own little game
like for example when
when uh
ttsa elizondo and melon
facilitated the release of those three
ufo videos at the end of 2017 early
2018. so you have the tic tac video you
get the go fast video and the
uh the gimbal ufo video those are three
that came out
so there was a whole discussion over a
metabunk run by uh mcwest
and they were debunking these they were
saying this is a hoax like the the video
is real but the audio's hoaxed
and i'm like no that actually turned out
to be complete nonsense
so just because medibunk may have their
own opinion doesn't mean even they're
legit or true
they can have their own agendas
so but what you do is you
when any information comes out you ask
yourself what is the origin
uh
how can this be corroborated or not if
there's no way to corroborate it
whatsoever then you got to be careful
like then don't throw all of your energy
into it
you know be careful
qualify what you know
there's a lot of gray baskets that stan
friedman said there's a lot of stuff in
that gray basket and you you better be
you got to learn to be comfortable with
uncertainty
in this field that's the name of a great
zen book it's one of my favorite books
on that subject zen but it's a good rule
for life
you better be comfortable
with
uncertainty
and so
know what you know know what you can
prove
construct your architecture around what
you can be cartesian
know what's know what you know
construct
a solid edifice
around what is known
and around things that you don't know
well then you
you do your best and you make qualified
assessments to the best of your ability
that's it
i say that's it like that's easy but
it's
not easy
but that's
that's all that i know how to do